lir a final game that kept us on the
edge of our seats until that last move
Rook to H1 and in fact it was a very
close game as well tell us your story
and your reaction to those last couple
of uh final final moves that decide the
game yeah well uh I it was a it was a
draw of course at the end I I mean uh I
knew it but uh uh there was this last
trick um I was very happy when I saw it
that I have this Rook H1 at the end and
he yeah he went for it so but I think he
defended quite well I mean I I I think I
should be winning at some point with the
two Rooks yes uh but I think once we get
to this Rook end game then then it
should be a draw because it's points to
to I think it was this moment after the
move Knight to E5 when objective leads
finally were entering drowish territory
oh yeah I thought I was still winning
but yeah maybe maybe not the case
anymore but before that it should should
be winning right yes yes before that it
was definitely winning but even this
position we were trying to understand
the ins and outs of uh this end game it
wasn't easy at all and in fact it was
this critical moment at this point after
the move Rook to H4 A6 was already
winning Rook to H4 was the big blunder
King to d8 yeah was the only move that
was Sav in the game yeah no I I didn't I
didn't see that I thought that his
intention was to play Rook H6 and then I
saw King C7 and I was very happy exactly
yes because this is winning and then I
realized ah it's Rook H4 what he wants
but then I quickly saw this line with
Rook H1 at the end and yeah again I was
extremely happy I thought um now he
needs some some kind of uh study to to
escape and but yeah it turns out he he
just didn't realize that this final
position was losing we were discussing
at the beginning of the show that you
you know the bunch of 2800s in the
tournament they really need to get some
victories to start catching up with
Fabiano who is uh right now on plus
three did you feel like this is a
must-win game for you in order to uh
still stay in the
race uh well yeah definitely it helps a
lot uh but uh yeah fa of course uh just
like last year he's trying to to run
away with it yeah it's it's not so easy
when when he scores almost every day but
uh but okay yeah it's it's nice at least
for me to to keep my chances after after
winning this game great game linear
congratulations guys any questions for
linear not for me just uh wow just great
watching you play lanir this end game
it's fascinating that he had a draw with
King d8 uh mystifying I want to say uh
but congratulations very important
Victory uh keep it
up thank you
absolutely I isn't that incredible that